what kind of projects does your
production company specialize in my
production company has done a lot of
sports documentaries but we've done all
kinds of documentaries series unscripted
reality
corporate videos sometimes you do one
for the meal one for the real
um so and and more recently our first
scripted so pretty much everything under
the storytelling gamut we've done
and so when you were still employed
as an employee you were setting up like
an LLC and getting all the paperwork
ready and yeah it's pretty easy actually
I mean just go to the Secretary of State
you get Incorporated
and I did that I had had some experience
trying to do little side hustles when I
had a job anyway like I had a personal
training business or I had a fitness
radio show and different things like
that so I knew to get Incorporated and I
had like I just said if I can just match
what I made at my job I'll be fine if I
could just match like that salary so I
had two projects set up and again it's
relationships that do people like
working with you are you easy to deal
with are you Cooperative it's just
striking that balance because I've met
filmmakers who are very talented but
they don't do well in that client
relationship they don't do well with
notes they don't do well and it's just
being able to strike that balance
so the first year I had my production
company
I doubled what I made at NASCAR which I
was happy with then like the following
year after that I doubled that so every
year I was doubling what I was making
from the previous year so it started it
was going really well
um
and so I would say if you're going to
start your own production company it's
easier now than ever but you have to
have some you do have to have some
infrastructure in place like I had a
cinematographer that I knew and also too
at the time I added I did it a lot
myself I edited my own work I directed
it I produced it I wrote it in fact
uh I don't know if I'm going too off
tangent but uh
this one guy who had a company like a
full production company with like a
staff of like 40 people
he was asking me on the book of Manning
he's like well who did this and I'm like
that was me and he said well who did
this that was me he's like who's your
production coordinator I'm like me so
um and he was asking like where did you
do your editing at and I just remember
talking to him on the phone I just
looked over and it was like a fold out
card table that I had in my gym at home
like that's where I did all the editing
like I didn't so I actually had bought a
book this might be helpful to viewers I
bought a book called rework which is
about why companies fail a lot in their
first five years and a lot of it is just
wasted money wasted resources like doing
things more for vanity like they think
they have to go to an office or they
have to have an assistant and you know
one of the biggest lessons was just
spend money on what you have to have and
that's what I did so I worked out of my
home
cap Cruise really minimal treated people
really well tried to do that
so
um that was helpful that book what do
you think some of the things that are
spent um on vanity aside from I mean
assistant you could say some of that's a
necessity so you don't burn out because
it is so so easy to burn out yeah being
on your own
um but but what do you think a lot of
people spend on vanity
um that that could be cut away well you
see a lot you saw it during covid
offices I mean think about how many
people started working from home during
covid and realize that they don't
necessarily have to go to an office I
saw it after I got divorced I have uh 50
custody of my kids so when I would get
hired like a lot of times they would
want me to come to LA and sit in the
edit Suite if I was working on a project
and I would say no like I'm not I'm not
able to do that or I could do it every
other week but this was uh
non-negotiable for me
and you can do a lot remotely like you
can do I think people are catching on
now but for a long period of time it's
like things were still being done from
like 20 years ago like how
a producer has to sit in the room with
the editor you have to be on location
you have to you know especially in post
um just things like that and and also
too I've seen treating all Productions
the same so a documentary shoot is being
treated the same as a commercial shoot a
commercial shoot is like huge I've done
commercials and there's people there who
are just like in charge of
walkie-talkies I mean there's like every
little job is like one person and on a
documentary you want to have a more
intimate uh crew and especially if
you're doing something really like
personal and emotional sometimes you
only want like three people with with
the subject if that
so they're different but I would see
some people applying that same
commercial mentality to a documentary so
those are some of the things I've seen
money being wasted on
how did you assemble your team and what
are some of the qualities you look for
in your collaborators
uh that's a good question
I assembled my team by people I've
worked with previously at the NFL and
NASCAR uh cinematographers audio editors
so I would say it's twofold
um Talent is important obviously but to
me not as important as uh being low
maintenance like I can't I can't stress
how important that is
um you want people that are going to go
with the flow you know like I'm looking
for Bruce Lee to be on my crew be like
water you conform to The Container
because production is constantly
changing it's not like accounting or
doing you know life insurance you go out
there especially in documentaries but in
scripted to what you think is going to
happen that day and what happens or
usually they don't line up all the time
so you want to be with people that can
be flexible and that you want to spend
time with like in a van like driving
down the highway so I and not everybody
may agree with this but I would rather
have somebody let's say that is a A
minus
cinematographer but I really like and
puts me in a good mood to be around than
someone who's an A plus and a huge pain
in the ass like that's me because to me
life is short and I have to spend time
with these people and I want to get a I
want to get along with who I work with I
don't look at it like work and personal
to me my work is personal because I'm
spending my time you know and it's uh
it's time I could be doing anything else
so
I would say the people I work with are
my friends uh genuinely and
um when it comes to documentaries some
people have and I've heard this been
said and to me by the way uh don't be
friends with your subjects don't be
friends you gotta keep that distance and
I see the argument in that but also
I think when you're friends with someone
you develop trust and when someone
trusts you they're more willing to be
open
um and I look at being friends that
sometimes you have to tell someone hard
truths
so it doesn't mean you're gonna
sugarcoat things and you know and I
think you just can get a better working
relationship when you are friends or at
least friendly with the subject
and I just did my first scripted feature
and uh we had our Premiere at the Santa
Barbara film festival and my parents my
parents came and my the one thing that
that uh touched me a lot was that my dad
said boy everybody that you work with
really uh likes you and they really seem
like they're your friends and I was like
great like that's awesome because I want
to be that way you know
um with the actors the crew and all that
so I try to hire people that I get along
with